do you like scary movies if you're a fan
of horror there have probably been quite
a few times where you found yourself
yelling at the movie screen don't go up
to the attic don't split up don't check
out the noise in the basement run out
the front door you know the characters
can't hear you but when the story is
engaging enough to make you care about
their well-being you can't help but try
and give them a hand after all you'd
want someone to save you from a
machete-wielding maniac stalking through
a summer camp you took up your new
counselor job at if someone was watching
you hide in the closet listening for a
masked killer's footsteps with a kitchen
knife in your hand you'd want them to
give you a heads up when the killer was
getting ready to chop through the door
with an axe of course the characters in
your favorite movies never listen
because you know that's how movies work
but in 1985 a young man returned a vhs
tape entitled return of the suburb
slasher to his local video store with a
peculiar complaint the main character of
the movie stopped mid action to look at
the camera and beg for his help the
video store clerk laughed him off and
refused to give him a refund though he
did eventually give in an offer store
credit after the man began to cry he
decided to take the tape home and watch
it just to see what all the fuss was
about after all he'd never seen someone
cry at a horror movie like that so he
sat down on his favorite beanbag chair
pushed the tape into the vcr and press
play apparently his shell-shocked
customer had at least remembered to be
kind and rewind the movie told the story
of heather campbell a young woman
planning to host a party at her family's
home in a classic suburban cul-de-sac
while her parents were out of town in
equally classic slasher fashion this
party would take place on the 10th
anniversary of a series of grisly
murders in the same neighborhood
committed by the mysterious suburb
slasher as the party kicks off with loud
music teenage debauchery and lots of
drinking out of red plastic cups the
killer appears to pick off the group of
friends one by one like other classic
slasher victims you're michaels and your
jason's the suburb slasher also covers
their face wearing a black burlap sack
over their head that masks all
identifiable features the first 90
minutes of the movie were fun but basic
a canoodling couple gets decapitated
here an unnecessary shower scene is cut
short by stabbing there the sort of
thing you'd expect but at about 97
minutes in something impossible happened
heather walked into the living room
finding her friend's dead body strewn
across it and let out a scream that
measured up to the bests in the genre
the teen scream queen then began to run
as the killer appeared to chase her she
made her way into the basement of the
house locked the door behind her then
she turned to the camera tears in her
eyes shirt spattered with blood and said
hey mister i don't know you and i don't
know why you've just sat there watching
this without doing nothing but please
i'm begging you help me out here what
can i do to survive this at first the
clerk thought he was under the influence
of some mind-altering substance but the
only things in his system were popcorn
and store brand soda now this was really
happening he stared open mouth at the
screen where heather watched him
expectantly he was too stunned to speak
after a moment of silence heather sighed
dejectedly shaking her head and turned
back toward the stairs she slowly walked
back to the basement door unlocked it
and pulled it open there the killer was
waiting with his expressionless burlap
mask the clerk's eyes widen and he cried
out no but it was too late the film
suddenly cut to black and with a
whirring sound the vcr spat the tape
back out the clerk sat there staring at
the tape what could he do with it should
he make a copy send it to someone else
and pass the curse along should he try
to watch it again he wasn't sure he
could bear to see heather looking at him
with those same pleading eyes then he
remembered an ad he had seen in the back
of his favorite comic book seeing
something you can't explain a brush with
the unknown keeping you up at night
we're looking for stories of the strange
and unusual write to us now maybe they
could do something he couldn't he put
the take back into its cover placed it
in an envelope and mailed it off the
next day a few days later the package
reached its intended recipient an
undercover branch of the scp foundation
tracking anomalous activity via series
of ads in comic books and video stores
to tap into one of the most under
utilized resource in the world nerds the
tape was designated scp-5733
and heather and the mass killer were
designated
scp-5733-2 and
scp-5733-1 respectively after an initial
viewing confirmed its anomalous
properties a research team headed by dr
carpenter began to perform a series of
tests testing was open to all foundation
employees subject to approval by dr
carpenter approved personnel would be
placed in a site-73 multi-purpose room
with a vhs player and a television the
staff member would then watch the movie
and attempt to engage with heather and
help her escape for the first test
d-class 1973 was selected when heather
turned to the camera and asked for help
he asked if she had a car when she
confirmed that yes she did he instructed
her to sneak back upstairs find her car
keys leave through the back door and
drive as fast and as far away as
possible she successfully retrieved the
car keys but when she reached the car
she saw that the tires had been slashed
heather began to panic but 1973 talked
her through it telling her to smash the
window of a neighbor's car and unlock
the door she complied in 1973 instructed
her on how to hotwire the vehicle the
car started and with a triumphant laugh
she sped out of the cul-de-sac just as
her car began to pull away the killer
emerged from the back seat wielding a
kitchen knife heather screamed and the
tape cut to black for the next test
d-class 1944 was selected he began by
telling heather to find her father
shotgun seen earlier in the film and
used it to take out the killer before
they could get to her she snuck up to
her parents room and found the gun only
for the killer to appear in the doorway
behind her she aimed the gun and fired
but nothing happened the killer opened
their hand dropping the shotgun shells
on the floor she was close but the
killer was one step ahead she screamed
as they approached with the knife and
again the tape cut to black after
several tests were conducted with
d-class subjects and no adverse effects
were reported aside from the obvious
trauma of failing to save heather's life
testing was opened up to all foundation
staff assistant researcher felissa baker
volunteered she believed her extensive
knowledge of the slasher genre would
give her the tools to help heather
strategize after speaking with heather
about her skills which mainly included
party planning and babysitting felicia
determined that heather should seek
outside help with felicia's help heather
made her way out of the house and over
to the home of her next-door neighbor mr
loomis when she got there the door was
open and the lights were off it didn't
look great but she didn't really have
much of a choice but to go inside she
made her way to the bedroom where mr
loomis and his wife were lying in bed
she tried to wake him but the camera
zoomed in to reveal his throat had been
slashed the shape in the bed next to him
sat up and was not in fact his wife but
the suburb slasher instead as the figure
raised their signature kitchen knife the
screen went to black
scp-5733 became a competition of sorts
among foundation staff each volunteer
proposing their knowledge would help
them get heather to safety assistant
researcher nick younglin daskowitz
proposed telling heather to call for
help giving her a secret phone number
for the scp foundation circa 1983
the time in which the movie was set
however when heather reached the phone
it had been destroyed smashed to pieces
next to it was a note written in blood
that said the only foundation here is
fear
then the killer appeared behind heather
and the tape went to black somehow the
killer knew about the scp foundation
perhaps in a manner of speaking the call
was coming from inside the house next
field agent malcolm pleasance and donald
mcdowell were selected due to their
extensive knowledge of hand-to-hand
combat they attempted to teach heather
various fighting and self-defense
techniques while she survived on the
limited supplies available in the
basement she eventually left the
basement and when the killer appeared
began to fight them after 23 minutes of
combat she knocked the slasher to the
floor and grabbed the candlestick to
finish them off as the agents watching
began to celebrate a second version of
the suburban slasher appeared behind her
lunging forward just before the new
killer made contact the tape cut to
black during this test the slasher
seemed more adept at combat than it had
been before as though it could hear the
advice being given to heather with other
techniques failing field agent tilda
joan bennett was brought in for a test
selected due to her expertise in
thalmaturgy she instructed heather on
basic offensive and defensive
thaumaturgy before guiding her out of
the house and into the front yard when
the slasher appeared brandishing their
knife heather was able to sign a
protective glyph and defend against the
knife's blow she followed this with a
wind spell that pushed the killer
further away heather began to run down
the driveway making a break for survival
when the slasher suddenly performed a
freeze spell that rendered her unable to
move heather's wide panicked eyes stared
down the barrel of the camera in a
silent scream as the killer approached
her recovered the knife in hand before
the tape went to black eventually dr
carper volunteered to conduct a test he
instructed his research team to prepare
a list of options for heather's survival
divided into four categories what to
take from the basement where to go once
leaving the basement how to exit the
house and how to escape the cul-de-sac
he was not informed about any of these
options but rather had them printed out
and placed into plastic bowls on the day
of the test there were also three cards
created and placed face down reading
face body and legs when heather
addressed dr carpenter he informed her
that he would be randomly selecting
instructions for her and asked that she
followed them exactly the first slip of
paper instructed heather to grab a pair
of garden shears from the basement and
climb the stairs back into the main
house next she was told to go upstairs
to the bedroom then downstairs into the
dining room she complied and there was
no sign of the killer so far third dr
carpenter told heather to run back
upstairs out of the bedroom window onto
the roof and then jump down into the
garden then it was time for the next
step he told heather to jump over the
fence into the neighbor's garden and run
down the street until she could find
help as heather made her way down the
road the slasher broke through the front
door of her house but did not chase
after her heather continued running down
the road for 20 minutes as the trees and
lights began to dwindle the surroundings
began to grow darker and darker until
they resembled a void dr carpenter
instructed her to keep walking she could
make out lights in houses in the
distance she ran toward the neighborhood
but stopped suddenly and began to panic
she was back in her own neighborhood in
front of her own house and the killer
was waiting for her as heather demanded
to know what to do carpenter flipped
over one of the three cards it read face
and so he told heather to attack the
killer's face with the shears then the
killer's legs then his body the killer
dodged her attack grabbed the shears and
pushed her to the ground as heather
looked up at the killer his face could
be seen through the torn sack it was dr
carpenter heather screamed and the tape
cut to black talk about a third act
twist the movie itself did not create
the killer but somehow the viewer did
and it also made the killer more
creative after this incident all testing
on
scp-5733 was suspended and attempts to
help turn heather from victim to
survivor were halted searching for
answers the foundation looked into
crystal elms productions the production
company listed on the videotape's cover
no record of the production company the
film or any of its casts could be found
several months after testing on
scp-5733 was suspended another tape was
found because let's face it baby these
days you've gotta have a sequel the new
tape was titled the suburb slasher
strikes again and was purported to be
produced by crystal elms productions in
1985.
it was designated scp-6733
unlike its predecessor this tape was
only tested once a member of d-class
personnel was first shown
scp-5733 up until the point where it
becomes anomalous and was then shown
scp-6733
he was left completely alone in order to
watch the contents of the tape the
following was what was on it dr malcolm
baines entered the testing chamber to
find d 1974 or jaime sitting across from
the television set he introduced himself
and ran a series of cognitive tests he
asked jamie what he thought of the film
and he said it was pretty much your
standard slasher film there's a group of
teens who just graduated high school and
go to a local camping site by a lake to
celebrate one of the mentions it's near
the site where the killer the slasher
was shot dead by police a year prior
after a rampage dr baines clarified
asking if this was a reference to the
first film jaime continued it's not
really clear they all think it's a joke
apart from the main girl she said her
dad's a police officer and she's seen
video evidence of the attack no one
references any of the characters from
the first film though and they don't
show up in this one either the slasher
is the only constant according to jaime
the main events of the film revolved
around a lakeside camping trip and
quickly began to go wrong dr baines
inquired about the nature of the
slasher's kills and jaime elaborated
he's still got a kitchen knife same
weapon as the first film so he stabs a
lot of them it's pretty gory for the
time it was made he slashes up someone's
face then the nerdy guy gets stabbed
through the eye that one's pretty good
the camera gets sprayed with blood one
of the teens gets his head crushed wide
open dr baines asked jaime how the
scenes made him feel and he responded
like there's some good jump scares and
the tension's fairly high at points but
it's a little dated i've seen scarier
but i've also seen worse horrors only
one part of the film stood out to him he
described it so the girl and her best
friend the one that's been looking out
for her this whole time enter into a
cellar the slasher creeps up from behind
and grabs the friend tears his head
clean off his neck the slasher then
chases the other teen to the other side
of the lake he's advancing on her the
camera's set on the water of the lake
it's a wide shot you've got the lake
waterline parallel to the top and bottom
of the shot so it splits the screen
horizontally she's fallen over crawling
away from him as he advances on her the
camera zooms in slowly though it takes
its time he does too there's music at
the start of the scene like deep dark
synths it stops as the camera moves
closer though i forgot to say it it's a
long scene longer than five minutes
maybe it was 10 i don't know it felt
longer than 10. so slasher's approaching
her we're the viewers approaching the
shore then the music stops and it's just
his footsteps and her pleading and she's
pleading man she's
there's these big inhales of breath
stifled by the mucus running out of her
nose she's babbling but it gets to the
point she's not even saying words just
making noise as jaime continued he began
to grow increasingly distressed the
camera's real close to the shore now and
the slasher stops
he turns his head and looks straight at
the camera you can't see his eyes but
you know he's looking straight at you
and he just stands there staring
eventually the girl crawls out of the
frame or the camera zooms past her i
can't remember which it just keeps
zooming in on his face where his face
should be under the hood the girl keeps
screaming off camera and then there's
this
guttural ripping noise and the screaming
stops it just stops but the camera keeps
moving you can see the individual
droplets of blood splashed across him
you can see the fabrics that make up his
hood his face soon takes up the entire
shot and then black no credits or
nothing the tape just cuts to black and
was pushed out of the player dr baines
pushed a bit asking if there was
anything anomalous he could be
forgetting then jaime thought of
something the girl
her friends all of them i i don't think
they had names jaime became increasingly
disturbed by the film over time calling
dr baines into his dormitory to ask him
if they had shown him a snuff film after
falling asleep he had a vivid dream of
the lake crawling alongside it recalling
the deaths of his friends at the hand of
a masked killer when he woke up he saw a
shadow outside the window of his room it
stood there silent and unmoving all
night it only vanished when the sun came
up the next night surveillance caught
the image of a humanoid shape running
through the forest but the guards found
no trace of it dr baines returned to
jaime's cell to find him deeply
distressed he repeated over and over
that the slasher was coming for him dr
baines dismissed this concern once jaime
was alone he stared into the mirror as
the temperature began to drop you're
here aren't you he said a gloved hand
punctured through the mirror spraying
glass everywhere on the other side there
he was the suburb slasher jaime fled his
dormitory and ran for his life as the
slasher followed him security officer
lauren confronted the slasher but they
lifted him up by the neck and stabbed
the familiar kitchen knife through his
head jaime continued to make his way
through the facility the slasher
following and leaving a trail of
destruction and bodies in his wake then
he reached dr baines who was confused by
his behavior dr baines insisted that he
needed to get to the basement but
terrified jaime resisted him the two men
scuffled and jaime shoved dr baines hard
sending him careening into the wall a
lighting rig fell from the ceiling
landing on dr baines several strangers
ran into the room calling for a medic on
set and asking for production and
lighting to come back and reset
everything off screen a director yelled
cut the slasher's face appeared taking
up the entirety of the camera and the
tape cut to black this version of the
tape's events was created after the tape
was watched by d 1888 in a testing
session with dr carpenter there has
never been a dr baines in the scp
foundation's employ somehow this second
tape creates a localized destabilization
of reality it is unknown how many times
it has actually been tested so be
careful what horror rentals you decide
to watch you might just find yourself in
the middle of the action and no matter
what you think you know about surviving
a slasher film there will be no escape
you can run
but you certainly can't hide now go
check out frightening lost ronald reagan
vhs tape you must watch
scp-1981 and scp-095
and
scp-5094 miss j's wizkid schoolhouse for
more mysterious media scps